I remember like wanting to like ask this
question but Catholic School couldn't
handle but you're saying no and so then
and so then it's like on top of that the
pastors have this reputation for
screwing the congregation right that's
like that's like yeah that's like that's
that's a common thing I guess it wasn't
it was I've heard it I've heard it I've
heard it here I've heard it in both
places but and I'm like why is there The
Stereotype they must do it a lot right
Justin Bieber's like priest or whatever
Pastor came out and I'm like no wonder
they preach forgiveness because he wants
to screw all the hoes and so what he's
saying is he's saying all of you guys
can wait I'm gonna screw them and add to
the bodies and then you guys can all
marry him after I'm done